there's going to be a resolution
eventually but it's just got to be one
that feels fair to our Union leadership
and look we voted 98 to two percent to
to to strike you know where if they deem
that that's what's necessary we ought to
protect the people who are kind of on
the margins and 26
000 bucks a year is what you have to
make to get your health insurance and
and there are a lot of people who
residual payments are what carry them
across that threshold and and if if
those residual payments dry up so does
their health care and that's absolutely
uh unacceptable they're already
affecting me not not
um I mean they've affected the whole of
Hollywood it's been going on for a while
whether it be writers directors act you
know it's it's something that affects
the entire industry
um and it's something that everybody
needs to be taken seriously in terms of
what it feels like today yeah it's a
very intense day but
the fact that I'm here and the fact that
I get to be with everyone is is a
wonderful feeling well I think it will
have a big impact on the whole industry
but I hope everyone gets what they want
I really do that's the most important
thing